charlena Mota gets up at 5:00 a.m. to
start her daily training session she's
the highest ranked Zimbabwean karateka
and she's working hard to make sure that
won't change anytime soon every day I
woke up with the money that's the first
thing in my mind I have to start
training so to me without Marshall Isis
no she'll be me
Charlene lives in Moo [ __ ] oh so close
to the Zimbabwean capital Harare the 27
year old is not only a fighter she's
married and has two young kids her
husband Michael supports her with a
little money he earns food always she's
coming out with something I think she's
like you and I'll keep on supporting it
the transit difficult was you know our
life here is still too difficult these
days
Michael buys and sells used cars
Charlene takes care of the household and
kids I myself because if you guys like
the guys I train it
they got wives they gain train from
morning up to evening because they know
there's someone could cook for them to
clean for them to wash for them but I
mean I have to train and three times a
week
Charlene trains a group of students in a
nearby school for her it's important to
change the perception that karate and
martial arts are for men only quite
challenging to beautify a female but as
we saw the skills we learned that karate
it's not all about gender it also gave
power to encourage other girls that they
can do anything which other guys can do
Charlene is on her way to South Africa
she was selected by the Zimbabwean team
to take part in a tournament finding
money for transport and training is one
of Charlene's biggest constraints and
she has to travel the whole night to get
there but the next morning Charlene is
bursting with confidence
we have no question we love this boy
today
yeah are you prepared about the
tournament well Pete no doubts the team
is headed by Zimbabwean karate legend
Sampson Lurie po the first African to
win the karate World Championship
he's one of Charlene's biggest
inspirations this is the first time
Charlene has officially competed outside
Zimbabwe she beats her opponent within
seconds much to the joy of her fellow
team members and travel more keep on
fighting every tournament every chance I
get
it's only resources that can keep us
from doing great globally otherwise it's
a great Mouse turn to her and the
youngster yeah young remaining is about
you